Raise your hand if you ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood. You got to have low
cholesterol diet. Otherwise, you're
going to get heart disease, right?
Doctors would like to blame all
cardiovascular disease on cholesterol.
We've known for 75 years in the animal
industry that cholesterol is not a
boogeyman. There's not a single disease
that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol or triglycerides. You can
find me one, I'll give you a million
dollars in small bills in any offshore
account you want. There's not a single
disease that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol or triglycerides. Elevated
blood cholesterol and triglycerides are
really just a warning signal much like a
fever. Fevers don't cause infections.
But when you have an infection with a
bacteria, a virus, a fungus, maybe a
parasite, you can get a fever. You can
have a broken leg and get a fever. You
can have cancer and get a fever. You can
have liver disease and get a fever.
Babies get a fever when they tee. And so
you have to kind of sort it out. When
somebody comes into a doctor's office
with a fever, you have to say, "Well,
okay, here's my whole list called a
differential diagnosis. all the things
that cause fever. If they're 80 years
old, you can quickly rule out teething,
right? But the rest of them you may have
to do some lab tests for. Any rate, the
same thing is true for elevated blood
cholesterol and triglycerides. When you
have elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides, it might mean that you
have hypothyroidism or low functioning
thyroid gland. You could have diabetes.
You could have deficiencies of nasin,
chromium, venadium, the essential fatty
acids. You could have liver disease. All
kinds of reasons why you might have
elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides, but they themselves don't
cause any problems. Now, the Eskimos
above the Arctic Circle have a
traditional diet that's 98% red meat and
blubber. Uh they eat whale meat, whale
blubber, walrus meat, walrus blubber,
seal meat, seal blubber, bear meat, bear
fat. There's not a single eskimo above
the Arctic Circle that has a Mr. Juice
Man juicer eats our gangly grown
broccoli. Their average cholesterol
ranges from 250 to 350. And yet, they're
legendary for not getting cardiovascular
disease until they come down to the
lower 48 and eat like us. Then when they
get the cardiovascular disease, they go
back home to die up above the Arctic
Circle, they start eating whale blubber
again. It goes away. Well, learning all
that, I felt very confident in telling
my patients, look, we're going to do
something different. My goal as a
physician is to have my patients die at
an average age of 100. I don't want my
patients down at 75.5. I want to give
them another 25 years. I want the
average lifespan for my patients to be
100. And we're going to do something
different. If you want to do everything
that all the other doctors and patients
are doing, I want you to go to them
because I don't want you to lower my
average, right? We're going to do
something different. It's just real
simple.